hello everyone and welcome to another
wonderful game from round six of this
year's singtel cup it is
and uh well not to spoil too much as
it's a very short game uh you will enjoy
this one and no we still don't know uh
what happened with Magnus and why he
left as soon as I know more I will
inform you so let's uh check out the
game alireza with the white pieces opens
with C4 he goes for the English opening
uh E5 by Mama jar of G3 and Knight to F6
The King's English variation Bishop G2
C6 and now Knight the F3 here D4 is by
far the more popular move but I think
that it just
um uh enters positions that both know
extremely well in this far to analyze so
you you can't really hope to achieve a
lot for example some like E4 D5 Bishop
to B for check Bishop to D2 now let's
say queen E7 defense Bishop E3 and so on
so it looks uh interesting but as it's
been played so many times I believe
alireza feels that the Knight to F3 will
give him a bit more chances with the
white pieces so he for now challenging
the Knight Knight D4 and pawn to D5 now
see captures in the now not C captures
but rather Queen capture Sandy for
developing the queen early on because
now Knight to C3 is impossible as the
Knight on D4 is hanging so you could
defend it with E3 but alireza just
brings the Knight back Knight to C2 and
now Queen to H5 already you can see that
mamidarov is ready to play some very
very aggressive chests here so H3
preventing Bishop to H3 and now Queen
the G6 it's uh it's a very good Square
for the queen for one it defends the
pawn on e4 as you know Knight to C3 is
coming and for two It prepares Bishop to
C5 and that will
uh of course mean a lot for example
Bishop C5 you castle and then Queen
captures on G3 so it's a very very
active Square for the black queen so
Knight to C3 Bishop to C5 uh and now uh
as you guys know you could uh try uh
playing this in many different ways but
like we said if castles then there's the
immediately winning Bishop captures on
H3 that's the problem it exposes the G3
pawn and if Bishop captures Queen
captures and white gets checkmated
Bishop G2 Knight G4 and that's pretty
much it but luckily allereza watches my
videos and he knows that in every
position for white B4 is always the way
to go so Pawn to B4 attacks the bishop
Bishop to B6 in now there is a game
where Knight the E3 was played but here
we have Bishop to beat you by alireza
and it is now as of move 11 that we have
a completely new game so Mom and Dad of
castles we have uh Knight the E3 now
that's not a knight we have Rook the E8
and queen to C2 now putting more
pressure on the E4 Pawn but as it's
always already overprotected it doesn't
really matter Knight beat the D7 and now
Rook to D1 so still uh not not eager to
Castle uh in the mamidara plays A5 he
wants to play captures and open up the
da file for his Rook so while it is a
place B5 uh and now Bishop to D4 the
idea being that now if alireza doesn't
capture uh mamidara will play C5 and
cement that Bishop on on D4 so Rook a
rook to B1 and now Pawn to C5 uh now uh
like I said cementing the bishop and D4
and here we have Pawn to H for preparing
Pawn to H5 and some lines so mamidarov
stops it and now here alireza could just
castle and we have a completely normal
game or he could play something like B6
uh you know if he's really adamant about
sacrificing that one lesson that
captures Bishop A1 opens up the B file
for The Rook so it's a one way to keep
things active but he chooses a knight
seat D5 and this uh well either he uh
blundered uh or or he maybe saw so deep
and far into the future that he actually
uh decided that this was good for him
but there are just captures Knight
captures on D5 and not captures and
plays Bishop captures an F2 check and of
course the problem is Queen F5 check
will win back the piece and you've just
allowed Bishop captures on F2 for no
reason so okay knight uh King captures
we have Queen to F5 check all it is a
goes back King D1 and queen captures on
D5 and all of a sudden uh the white king
is unable to Castle in the will black
should be should be a whole lot better
so Rook to F1 alireza brings the rook in
their game alireza does have
compensation as the rook and the bishop
are very strong here but with with some
decent play shouldn't be a problem and
by decent play uh of course I mean you
have to play a move like B6 and the file
it is a try something like Queen to C3
you play F6 and then the position holds
uh the problem is after mommy there was
next move uh that's exactly what he
cannot play he plays Knight to f8 and it
makes sense he wants to play Knight E6
then bring the Knight to D4 if he can do
that he basically wins the game but now
alireza plays Queen to C3 and now the
problem is F6 no longer exists if F6 now
alireza can just take it Rook captures
and F6 and if G captures Queen captures
there's no stopping Checkmate here uh
there's no defense against Queen G7 and
queen trade if you dress I'm like Queen
D7 to stop Checkmate you you get Queen
h8 check King F7 Queen G7 King E6 and
I'll Bishop H3 is enough to uh you know
just win the game for white so Miami
Dara plays Knights the E6 but it's such
an ugly move to make now the Knight must
remain here to prevent Checkmate and
while the Knight is here you can't
really develop your Bishop your Rooks
don't have a way of entering the game
and there's really no good a good uh
gameplay here so while it is a place
Rook F4 beautiful move uh attacks uh d e
for Pawn so you have to worry about that
and also it's uh just just a very active
Square uh for for the for the Rook you
can't capture it of course if the Knight
moves again you get checkmated uh so
here mommy madeirao just has to accept
that there is no saving the pawn he has
to play something like Bishop D7 allow
the capture play Queen D6 and the game
continues but this is something that
often happens when you've had a winning
position or close to winning and your
opponent suddenly equalizes you feel
like you still have the the right or
rather the privilege to uh or you know
whatever to just just still be winning
in the position even though that's not
the case so here Mommy get power plays
F5 he wants to defend everything and
hopefully continue his attack but now
alireza just plays D3 and now how do you
play this again the E4 Pawn will fall if
if you capture this then just Bishop
captures on D5 you lose the queen so
that's impossible what can mamidara play
the only way to play this is Queen
captures an A2 and it's still not a fun
way for uh for uh for mummy of to do
this because after Rook A1 attacking the
queen queen D5 uh D captures an E4 uh
what do you play you have to play Queen
D4 or for a queen trade and now you are
you are still in the game for example
Queen captures Knight captures Bishop
capture C captures and now e captures an
F5 undoubling uh restoring material
balance and uh well keeping a better
position as this Pawn will now be weak
the white king will very easily go after
it so probably you will lose at least
one Pawn over the course of time but uh
that is the best way to play this
momentaro played Knight the D4 it's a
very very active move now you've
activated your knight you no longer have
to worry about the Checkmate but he
misses one very important thing feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the only winning move for alireza while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this wild
wild idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Pawn to E3
a very very simple stuff and that's
exactly what holiday is a played and it
seems like there's so much that you can
do here with black the the reality is
that there's really not because even if
you play something like Knight F3 check
we just capture it and Checkmate is
still being threatened so you can't
really play that what can you play if
you go Knight back to E6 now it's a
completely different story because the
E4 Pawn just Falls D captures on e4 and
whatever you play that is just lost if
you play Queen captures and A2 now uh
just Rook day one and your queen is
trapped there's no square for the queen
and even if you don't play that after
the characters on e4 you can play F
characters on e4 just Bishop captures
and there's just no no playing this
queen D7 you're gonna play Rook to D1
you can go after the queen if Queen E7
Bishop D5 now pins the Knight it's just
disgusting so after this E3 movement
there will play Queen captures an A2
right away but it's not not much better
Rook to A1 Queen back to E6 now D
capture is an E4 and he was in this
position unmove 2018 that shot resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here if you capture of course uh
it's uh uh just you know a simple recap
or rather capturing of the piece on the
forms e captures on D4 and that's it C
captures Queen captures your position is
completely lost now you're down material
Checkmate is being threatened if Rook is
seven Rook capture Sunny for you just
fall apart completely and uh uh other
than that after the characters any four
you could play some like Queen G6 hope
to get some Queen G3 action in but still
after he captures on D4 uh the queen
guards the the G3 pawn and okay you
could play C captures Queen captures
Queen captures with check seems like uh
there could be something there but there
would be a winning idea and that is
Queen to F2 uh just defending everything
and after Queen moves and now we're
gonna play Rook to C1 you're gonna push
the pawn you're gonna uh there's really
no no way to play this for black so I'm
sure if mamidaro wasn't uh so disgusted
with himself he would have tried this
and maybe continued playing uh because
well if all it is I can blunder so so
can my mind and so can alireza again but
I I think he was just so mad at himself
that he just resigned on the spot and
it's a very very good example of how I
mean alireza blunders this uh Bishop
captures an F2 idea uh you think to
yourself okay I can never lose this I
can only win this now and then you just
play this uh Knight The Fate move which
allows uh which allows this makes F6
impossible and you become very very
angry and then you just uh even though
you could like the game is still equal
you could still play it but uh it it's
you know it takes incredible mental
capacity to go from a winning to not
winning and still you know fight with uh
you know the the same Vigor you would be
fighting as if your position was winning
so uh you know something to consider
maybe in your own games no you know okay
not online ones but maybe in in in real
ones you know the classical ones or you
know if you can pull it off in Blitz
even better but yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it very nicely
done by alireza who uh just comes back
after after a blunder like that here
understanding if you missed the the
previous video so Wesley leading the
tournament followed by Fabiano Corona
alireza and the animation with three
points with two and a half points uh
Levon Hans and linear Dominguez with two
points Maxima Sherlock and yarov really
not having the best tournament with one
and a half point in last place currently
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it if you haven't seen it do
check out the previous video where
Wesley played against Hans Niemann it
was quite the game or rather Neiman
played against Wesley Wesley had the
black pieces it was a beautiful game I
would like to thank would Paul
certainovich csfi ravishing reptiles
YouTube and another casual encoder for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
singfield cup until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day